the laptop is made up of about 20
components that are sourced all around
the world we start with a bear chassis
and the first thing we installed is the
motherboard the motherboard is what
connects all the other devices together
inside of the computers from there we
have the hard drive memory the
microprocessor the keyboard the LCD sub
assembly which includes the camera any
wireless or Bluetooth devices and then
we connect all of the ports and route
all the cables inside which is the most
tedious aspect of building our ThinkPad
computers after they're assembled they
go through a test process to make sure
they were assembled properly that
includes checking all of the touch
capability every port and all mechanical
functionality on the system it goes into
a run in area where it gets the
operating system loaded and has some
extended hardware testing once that
process completes it goes to our
packaging area where it gets its quality
inspection and gets packaged with its
accessories so from the start of the
process where we're installing the
motherboard into the bare chassis
approximately 45 operators work on each
system it's manufactured here it takes
about six hours from the start of the
process where we're packing the unit up
and it's ready to shipment to a customer